Hey, everybody.
Welcome to Roll Back.
What is Roll Back?
I'm so glad you asked.
Roll Back is where we share the best conversations
from our pre-video audio only catalog with you
right here on YouTube for the very first time.
And today we bring you the story of the man
who fast talked his way into a recording contract
right out of college, the man who co-created
and sold companies like Marquis Jet and ZICO Coconut Water,
the guy who co-owns the Atlanta Hawks NBA franchise
with a few friends, and freely shares his wisdom
and his experience in a very entertaining way
on his highly popular and quite addictive Instagram account
inspiring millions of people across the world.
I'm talking of course
about the one, the only, Jesse Itzler.
Jesse is quite the character.
He eats only fruit before noon, he runs 100 mile races,
he raises millions for charity,
and when he isn't playing super dad to his four kids,
he's an in demand motivational speaker
with a life highlighted by one predominant theme,
never be afraid to fail.
And despite all of his many successes, in 2010,
Jesse felt that his life had kind of settled
into a too comfortable routine.
So he did what any rational human would do, right?
He invited a Navy Seal to move in with him,
but this was no ordinary Navy Seal,
this was the one and only David Goggins.
And Goggins accepted Jesse's invitation on one condition,
and that condition was for 31 days,
Jesse had to do every single thing
that David asked him to do, no exceptions.
And the result was Jesse's book Living with the Seal,
which was the subject of this exchange from episode 197
that was recorded way, way back in November of 2015.
So please hit that subscribe button and enjoy this very old,
but still very relevant conversation with Jesse Itzler.
I've been wanting to meet you for a long time, man.
So this is super cool.
I feel like you're like this sort of Gen X version of Zelig,
you've lived all these different lives
and different chapters in many different ways in a really-
We have that in common.
In a cool way.
You know, I was trying to think
as I was driving over here, I was like,
"What is like the overarching sort of theme
or marching order of your life?"
And it really boils down to, I think,
and correct me if I'm wrong, but being fearless,
not being afraid to fail, and allowing yourself
to get out of your comfort zone,
which is obviously a predominant theme in the new book.
Yeah, no, definitely.
I think that sums it up pretty good
and doing things differently,
just not intentionally differently,
but just looking at challenges and saying, "You know what?
that would be a great on my life resume."
The resume that you refuse to write down though.
Correct.
You be like, that's the thing, right?
You've never had a resume.
Right, right.
Just a life resume in your mind.
Yeah, cool
Yeah.
So, I mean, where do you think that...
Where does that germinate from?
I mean, were your parents like that?
Where did that kind of sensibility come from?
Well, first of all,
it's a lot more fun living outside,
living outside of your comfort zone
and trying different things.
But I've always been a check the box guy.
You know, finish one thing and not really dwell on,
oh, that was a good accomplishment or whatever
and just look for the next challenge.
I've always just always wanted to kind of keep going
and keep trying to find new things that would excite me.
I get bored easily.
So I'm one of the, I guess, so many of us need a goal
or something to train for.
So I'm always looking for the next thing,
whether it's business or physical or whatever.
Were you like hyperactive as a kid?
Did you have trouble like sitting down in class?
I didn't recognize that at the time,
but now that I look back on it, for sure.
Yeah, yeah.
You would've probably been medicated if you were a kid now.
Yeah, I know, I know.
For not being able to focus
and everything like that.
Well, I mean, we can track back
and go through the music career
and all your kind of entrepreneurial ventures,
but let's camp out in the book right now.
Sure.
Tell me a little bit about the book
and kind of how this whole thing got sparked.
Sure, well, the book's called Living with a Seal
and I was at a 24 hour race in San Diego a couple years ago
and I was running the entire race
as part of a six person relay team with friends.
And the guy next to me,
literally set up his little station next to me,
was running the entire race alone.
And he caught my eye because he was about 265 pounds,
which is a lot of weight to carry in a 24 hour race
that you're running by yourself.
And the race was unsupported,
so we had to bring all of our own supplies.
And at the time I just sold the company
and I probably overdid my supplies,
I had a tent, a masseuse, bananas,
like I think Whole Foods pulled up.
And this guy next to me literally sat in a folding chair
with a bottle of water and a bag of crackers
with his arms crossed
with this don't even think about messing with me look.
And I was just like, "Who is this guy?"
And at mile 70, he had broken all the small bones
in both of his feet and had kidney failure.
And I watched this guy, literally just on pure guts,
finish this race.
And I was like, "Who in the world is this?"
So I Googled them, he had a fascinating backstory,
which we can get to if you want.
And I decided I wanted to meet him.
I cold called him and I literally just picked up the phone,
called him, he wasn't super chatty.
So I said, you know what?
Yeah.
Let me get on a plane and come see you.
And after about 10 minutes of just sitting with him, I said,
"My life would be a lot better
if whatever he had psychologically,
whatever made this guy tick, rubbed off on me a little bit."
And I invited him to move in with my family and I
and three days later, he was at our breakfast table.
And the idea was,
he's gonna live with you for 31 days
and the only rule is that you've gotta do everything
that he says or he asks of you.
Yeah, and I wanted to get in great shape.
At the time, I was in a good routine
or I thought it was a good routine.
And so many of us live our life on routine
and routines are great, but there definitely could be a rut.
And I wasn't getting better.
My routine was great, but I wasn't improving
in any of the buckets in my life.
But you're such a high performer
in so many other areas of your life.
Like your bar is already set pretty high
in comparison to the average person.
So to me, it takes a deep level of self-awareness to go,
"No, there's still room there."
Yeah, I mean,
at the time I was doing a bunch of marathons,
my times weren't getting better,
my training, wasn't I was just doing it.
I was going through the motions,
but I wasn't at all giving it my all
and I couldn't get that mojo, it's hard.
You know, the one thing that he really taught me,
and I'm sure you can relate to this
through everything you've done,
is we're all disciplined in our own ways,
but to be consistently disciplined,
consistently disciplined, is so hard.
That's the hardest part.
Right, and he was the most of the most
of the highest level of consistency and discipline.
His name is David Goggins.
And since in the book, I referred him as Seal,
but his name is David Goggins.
And he came in and he just turned everything upside down
from day one.
And how much of it was purely
like I just want to get in physical,
great physical condition, versus beyond that,
like sort of the mental discipline, the emotional discipline
that would spill over into other areas of your life?
Like were you thinking about that at the time
or was this purely like a fitness bootcamp?
When I first kind of put my hand out
and shook his hand across from the table and said,
"He'll move in with me," it was predominantly,
I wanted to get in great shape,
but after two hours of him at my house,
it flip flopped and the psychological side of it
and what makes him tick and how is he so driven
became 80 to 90% of it.
So I knew I was gonna get in good shape,
that was unavoidable, I mean, he's a machine,
but I really wanted so much more
because you go in and outta shape,
you go through these peaks and valleys, up and down,
but the mental side of it,
you can really can last a lifetime.
Right.
And I got all these different little sound bites
and tidbits of living with him.
I mean, the first day that he came here
in two hours into our journey, we went down,
he wanted to see how many pull-ups I could do.
And by the way,
he has set the Guinness Book of World's Records
for most pull-ups in a day on 4,030 in 17 hours.
So pull-ups for him weren't that difficult.
Pull-ups for me, a 200 pound guy,
that doesn't do any, was very tough.
So I squeezed like eight.
He said, "Alright, get off the bar
and try it again in 30 seconds."
Got back on the bar, I did like maybe six.
He said, "One more time, wait 30 seconds, and try it again."
And I barely got four and he turned
and I was done, like lactic acid built up,
my arms were like at a 90 degree angle.
And he turned to me and he said,
"All right, we're not leaving here
until you do 100 more."
And I said, "I can't possibly do 100.
Like impossible for me to physically,
I might wanna do it, I can't do it."
And he said, "No, you can do it.
And I'm gonna prove it to you.
We're not leaving this gym until you do it."
So I would do one, walk around the gym, do another,
but what he taught me and I did it,
but what he taught me is we all have so much more
in our reserve tank than we think we have.
And his saying, one of your saying
that has resonated with you
is that when your brain tells you you're done,
you're really only 40% done.
And he taught me that right there.
He kind of-
Yeah, I had heard him say that one time
and I never forgot it.
And as we were kind of chatting before the podcast,
that's something that I use in the talks that I give
and also it was a big sort of mantra
when I was doing EPIC5, when I would hit those low moments.
And it's so true, it's so incredibly true
and it's incredibly powerful.
And when I'm reading your book,
you refer to him as Seal, he's anonymous.
But to me, immediate, I'm like,
I know immediately,
there's the only person this could be is David Goggins.
Right, right.
Like anybody in the endurance community
would identify him immediately,
'cause there is no other human being like this guy
on planet Earth.
Right.
But I'm interested in why it was anon.
I know that it now it's public,
I think maybe a week ago or whatever,
he was cool with like coming out and doing press about it.
But was he reticent to participate in this on a media level?
Or like what was the reason why he was anonymous
throughout until recently?
Well, when he moved in with me,
I decided to keep a blog of our training regiment
and I sent it out to just 30, 40 friends.
And during that time, I just referred to him as Seal
just 'cause I thought it was funny,
it resonated with guys, and the blog really caught on
and it led ultimately to this book
and I just wanted to keep it consistent with the blog.
There wasn't like anything deeper than that.
But I also wanted people that didn't know,
like you, David Goggins and the name,
or could Google him or whatever,
to get their own mental vision
of what this guy looks like and is.
Right.
Yeah, it's so interesting.
And for people that are listening that don't know who he is,
he's a Navy Seal, he's been a Navy Seal for like,
I don't know, over 20 years probably at this point
who has suffered the loss of many a fellow soldier
and around, I think, I wanna say it was around 2007 or so,
to honor his fallen brethren,
I think he had six friends of his
who died in helicopter accident or so something like that,
decided that he was gonna tackle
the 10 most challenging endurance challenges on the planet.
Right.
And he just said about like checking the boxes.
You know, he'd never been a runner.
The guy's enormous, right?
Like he is not like the typical triathlete runner,
he never owned a bike.
You know, like on sheer force of will, he, one-by-one,
knocked these things off.
And he, I don't know how he got into his first 100 miler,
I think he had to do something on a track
to prove that he could do it,
and that was another instance, I think,
where he broke all kinds of bones.
Well, that's the race that I saw him at.
I saw him at his first one.
Oh is that the one?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Unbelievable.
And on a personal level,
when I was going through like my transformation
and my journey,
I was trying to think of a challenge
that would get me excited and scared
and all of those things and was contemplating an Ironman
when I picked up a magazine article,
and I talk about this in Finding Ultra,
and it was a story about this race, Ultraman,
but really it was a story about this guy, David Goggins,
who had come off bad water, had never really,
I don't think he'd ever even done a triathlon at all,
and had gotten into this Ultraman race,
didn't own a bike, borrowed a bike,
didn't have cycling shoes or cleats or anything like that,
he actually taped his tennis shoes to his pedals.
And through this incredible mental acumen that he has
and force of will, still placed relatively high
in this race and I was so amazed by that.
But that was like the seed that was planted for me
to contemplate the idea that perhaps I could try this race.
And so he's sort of a spirit animal to me.
I mean, I've met him a couple times.
I wouldn't say that I know him well,
but truly a remarkable human being in every category
and unlike any other person you're ever gonna meet.
And an unlikely roommate for my wife and I.
Yes, perhaps the most taciturn and serious,
gravely serious person I've ever encountered.
When he walked into my house,
and this is in the book,
I said, "You know, look.
Go ahead, take your bags, make yourself at home."
And he said, "Nah."
He said, "I don't have a home.
This is your home."
And I said, "No, make yourself at home as an expression."
And he turned right to me and he goes,
"I don't operate in expressions."
I was like.
(Rich laughs)
You're like, "This is gonna
I'm like, "Okay."
be a long 31 days."
'Cause you're like a jocular fun guy, you know?
You must be thinking like,
"There's gotta be a way into this guy.
Like how am I gonna crack his emotional core
and get to the reality of like who this person is."
Right, I also thought look, we'll run,
we'll watch some football games, we'll go to some dinners.
You know, like that was the thing.
(Rich laughs)
That got thrown out the window.
He literally took, we lived at the time in New York City
in a great building on Central Park West,
he took all the furniture in the guest room
where he was sleeping, moved it to the side,
and blew up an inflatable tent
that takes the oxygen out of the room
to increase your like red blood cell whatever
and slept in a tent in our apartment.
Like an altitude tent.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, there's amazing anecdotes in the book.
There's one story where I think you come in
and he's just sitting in front of the window,
like looking out the window.
Yeah, this window.
Like his ability to just patiently
and quietly sit without encountering
Or stalk.
Any distractions, yeah.
Or stalk, yeah.
Is quite amazing.
So how did it go when you cracked this news to your wife?
Like, "Hey, here, I got this idea.
This is what's gonna go down."
So well, my wife is an entrepreneur,
she owns a company called Spanx,
and she's always lived her life way out of the box.
She's put herself out there, she's a huge risk taker,
that's a theme in her life.
And I always say, she's 50% Einstein and 50% Lucille Ball.
And I think when I told her
that we're having a guest move in,
I got her at a Lucille Ball moment
because she didn't really register with her.
So I immediately went to onto the next thing.
I kind of got like a half approval
and went on to the next topic.
Yeah, it's not really registering
what that's actually gonna mean.
And I said it really fast.
Like we're having a guest Navy Seal.
You know, like subliminally kind of snuck it in.
So I could tell her that I gave her the information,
but I didn't give her all the information.
And so tell me the first thing
that happens when he comes in.
So well, first of all,
he came for 31 days with nothing.
All his belongings were in a small backpack,
which was amazing 'cause it was the winter.
And I showed him to them.
Like I told you, we went down
and did these pull-ups, did that pull-up challenge.
And...
That was right when he arrived.
Right outta the gate.
And then that night, he told me that I'd be sleeping
in a chair to get outta my comfort zone.
And he wanted me to feel what suffering
to start to feel what suffering is,
so I could enjoy it as he would say.
But no, every day he had an expression.
Every day, we have to do something that sucks.
And we did.
And he wanted me to take my baseline,
which I thought I was operating at a high level,
and just really reset it and raise the bar
because once it gets reset, your baseline just gets raised.
You can't really go back.
And all the challenges, all the workouts,
we did some crazy stuff, jumped in a frozen lake,
we did insane runs in blizzards, and all this other stuff,
but it was all about raising the baseline to get better
and getting outta your comfort zone.
You know, that term is overused,
but the only way to really get better is to experience pain,
to get uncomfortable, and to go to places
that you don't want to go and improve.
Right, and it's interesting for a guy like you
because I mean, literally,
you have choices most people don't have.
Like you could choose to spend your time
however you like without really a concern for resources.
And most people in your scenario would opt
for sort of lavish vacations and whatever,
like the path of least resistance
and sort of only doing things
that sort of pique your interest.
And here you are kind of welcoming this person
into your life that is gonna completely shake that up
and force you to confront yourself
in a way that you could go to your grave
without ever having to do and be none the wiser
or suffer nonetheless.
And I think that's why he decided
to move in with us I think.
And that was my next question.
Like why would he agree to do this?
I think that he recognized
that there was authentic passion for wanting to get better.
There was a strong appreciation for him.
I had so much respect for what he was doing
and what he's done for our country.
And I think part of him too,
I think, to live with two entrepreneurs,
I think there was a little bit of like,
let me see what another world looks like to him.
That's about as uncomfortable for him
as it is for you to jump to a frozen lake.
Absolutely.
'Cause it's hard to even picture that guy
in New York City at all,
let alone like sort of in your fancy apartment building.
I know.
No.
I mean it's comical.
It was.
And the book's fun,
I mean, that's the whole fish outta water part of the book.
It's really funny.
But yeah, I mean, women with poodles in their pocket books
or in the elevator, with him,
he's probably jumped outta parachutes
in foreign countries and done things some other stuff
that's I don't even know about
that helped our country and this and that.
And here he is in this fancy building
and he was just so determined at everything.
I mean, everything was perfect form,
perfect execution, on time.
And a lot of that rubbed off on me.
You know, not just physically, but even at work.
You know, I've lost many deals to just negotiation fatigue.
You know, I don't have great negotiation endurance.
I'd rather run a lot of times.
I'll just be like, "You know what?
It is, what it is.
I'm not gonna, I wanna go run.
Fine, done, shake on it."
And he just, everything that he did in his life,
even the way he cleaned his room in the beginning,
or made his bed, was perfect, it had to be done.
In fact, this is really interesting,
I asked him now, "What else is left on your bucket list?
Like you've done all these amazing things."
And he said to me, literally, this is two days ago.
he said, "There's nothing left,"
he's done everything he wants to do,
what he's doing now is he's going back
through the things that he's already done like Badwater
that he thinks he could do better
and trying to improve the things on his bucket list
that he's already done.
Interesting.
Yeah, one of his kind of pearls of wisdom throughout
that's peppered throughout the book is this idea
that it's less about what you're doing,
it's when you're doing it and how you're doing it.
And that like commitment to doing whatever you're doing,
however mundane it is, to do it the best
that you can do with this relentless focus,
like the ability of him to like be super present
in whatever he is doing without any distraction.
Right.
Now part of that is he has the luxury
of having a super simple life, right?
He doesn't have a lot of distractions and...
Yeah, he's not on Facebook or Twitter.
No, no
Why would he do that when he could be doing pushups?
Exactly.
But that's part of it.
But I always felt like during our days
that we were operating with 27 or 28 hours in a day,
I was so more efficient at work,
even though I was doing so much more physically
and we were training so long,
I was getting so much more done at work
because all the non-essential things
that he would just be like, "Eliminate 'em."
Meetings, maybe I would take that.
I didn't eat lunches, this and that.
And he would find, you know,
a lot of us think if we don't work out in the morning,
ah, I miss my workout, I'll do it tomorrow.
If we had a 15 minute break during,
he shadowed me everywhere I went,
he came to every meeting, every meal, everything.
And if they'd be like, let's take 15 minute break
to check emails and go to the bathroom.
He'd be like, "Let's go do as many burpees
as we can in 10 minutes
and then take five minutes to do your stupid emails."
Yeah, and there was that time
where he made you do that during a break
and like a negotiation or a business meeting
and you're in a suit and you have to come back all sweaty.
Yeah, yeah.
Just finding that little sliver of extra time
throughout your day.
And you're always working out.
And he didn't care.
Like it's not like you worked out and you're done,
like it's a constant search for that little moment of time
that you could maximize and use more efficiently.
And he did.
You know, if we were traveling
and we would get home at 11 o'clock
and he felt like the day wasn't complete,
like we didn't get enough done,
he would say, "All right, we'd still have 50 minutes left.
We're gonna maximize those 50 minutes in the day."
Were you game throughout?
Was there ever a moment where you're like,
"All right, man, come on."
Or a breaking point where you're like,
it's too much or you thought you weren't gonna make it?
Several times, several times.
And I just didn't wanna let him down.
You know, it was just so motivating.
It's one thing to read about inspiration,
it's another thing to live with inspiration.
And when I was just being around him
and knowing what he's done, like you said,
taping his feet to a bike and all this crazy stuff,
I can't go out for a 50 minute run?
I mean, it was just impossible to say no to him.
And then after two or three weeks, when it became habit,
I would look forward to it.
I'd be like, "Oh, I can't wait for it to suck today."
Interesting.
And so it was really interesting.
And I would bring 'em to these business meetings.
And I remember specifically,
we went to meet with Kevin Garnett,
who at the time was playing with the Celtics,
who was a Gatorade endorser, you know,
he was an endorsed for Gatorade.
But he was also really into what he puts in his body
and his contract was coming up.
And we thought for my coconut water company, ZICO,
he'd be a great fit as an endorser.
So I brought Goggins with me and we go to pitch in Boston,
Garnett, and I introduced them and I said,
"Oh, this is David Goggins, he's a Navy Seal.
He's living with me to train me."
And for the next two hours,
those guys just went back and forth about fitness.
You know, what they put in their body,
food, this and that.
And then in the end, they gave each other a bear hug
and they said, "All right, great meeting."
And I'm like, "What about ZICO?"
And Garnett turned to me and he said,
"Look, whatever you guys are doing, I'm in."
So he was like the-
The ultimate closer.
Without question.
Guys were so fascinated with him.
I was, was like, I wish I could bring him everywhere.
Just an incredible accessory
that you could bring into the boardroom.
No, there's you paint that scene really beautifully,
'cause it starts off you being nervous
about how this is gonna go and this negotiation,
you bring David in, and immediately,
like Kevin is in this sort of staring contest,
like trying to figure out who this David guy is,
he's not hearing anything that you're saying.
Nothing.
Right.
It's really great.
It's Hysterical.
And I'm going through a whole pitch,
and then he just turns to Goggins.
He's like, "So what do you do during a day?"
You know, that was it, the floodgate's open.
And those guys had their conversation and...
I don't think there was anybody
who could beat David in a staring contest.
No.
No way.
Right?
(Rich laughs)
And also I love the part about like sort of just walking,
like walking across midtown
and you're wearing like 50 pound weight vests
and he's got his eyes, it's like, he's in Fallujah.
You know, he's like spotting,
we gotta across the street,
like looking for enemy sightlines the whole time.
Yeah, he had these, we got two weight vests
that we would wear when and walk to work.
I would wear a suit somedays, not often.
You're wearing the weight vest
underneath your suit?
Yeah, underneath it.
And some days over it, but usually under.
But sometimes it would be exposed
and we look like we're gonna go blow up a building.
I mean, he looks-
Did anybody ever stop you?
People, they couldn't stop us,
'cause they run to the other side of the street.
I mean, they were freaked out.
I was freaked out.
I thought like it was unsafe.
This is 2010, right?
When this was happening.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
So he loved the weight vest.
He'd wear the weight vest like he would put it on
like he was putting on the jacket after he won the masters.
I mean celebrate it.
He would welcome it, he would sleep in it,
he loved, he just loved challenge.
It couldn't be hard enough.
And he, as I recall, I think he had a heart thing
that was going on with him that took him out,
like 'cause he didn't compete for a number of years.
And then he was kind of gone.
Like I didn't see him anywhere,
I didn't see his name anywhere,
I think that might have been around 2009
or something like that.
Did he have surgery or did they got rectified
or how did that get?
So he accomplished
all these amazing physical feats
with literally, I believe, like 60%,
only 60% of capacity of his heart.
He had a huge hole in his heart and he has sickle cell.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Yeah, he has sickle cell.
So it's just an amazing story.
I mean, anyone listening should Google David Goggins
and get more about his story
or a lot of it is in my book Living with a Seal,
but it's just guys like this are rare
and when you can pull things out of their journey
to help your personal life,
whether it's training or work, and I was fortunate,
I got both out of it, it just makes you so much better.
Yeah, it's a lost sensibility in our culture.
You know, now it's all about the life hack
or what's the shortest route to get to the end game,
and here's a guy who's so fully committed to the process,
the journey, he's actually seeking out
the most difficult route as opposed to finding the shortcut.
And in that, finding the thing to celebrate is overcome.
You know, it's like if it's easy to do then what is that?
What are you gaining out of that?
It's only through confronting and overcoming
and getting to the other side of that thing
that you thought you could never do that enriches your life.
And also I would just add one thing,
so many of us have finish lines.
I'm gonna run the New York Marathon,
and when you train for that one specific thing,
you celebrate it with a party with your friends,
you hang the medal up and the pictures up and you said,
"Okay, it's on my resume.
I did the New York Marathon."
He has no finish lines.
No.
It's like, once that's done,
what's the next race?
You know, what's the next thing to do?
Yeah, he was in 12th
Check the box.
for one second.
I think he did Ironman world championships one year,
he parachuted into the swim, did the whole Ironman,
and when it was done, he went out for a run.
He's like, this is another workout.
Right.
Like he doesn't make too big of a deal
out of anything.
Right, right.
So that's a valuable lesson as well.
So what are like the biggest lessons
that you take away from this?
Like how has this impacted your life post David?
I mean, it's been five years now,
what are the biggest changes that have stuck with you
that are still part of your daily life?
Well, for starters, definitely the same,
just to reiterate what you dwelled,
you tapped into on one of your races, the 40% rule,
something that definitely resonates with me,
I always think about.
But just on a daily basis, he's just motivated
to live a lot more with a lot more grit.
Grit is a great indicator of future success
and he was the grittiest,
but just to live my life with as much grit,
look for challenges that maybe stuff
that I don't think I can complete and try to do it,
always have something on my calendar
that I'm looking forward to, that I can train for,
and then what's next after that?
I'm building out a schedule.
I'm way more efficient with my time.
I've eliminated a lot of the non-essential stuff in my life.
I'm trying to live more simply.
My life's a little complicated, his life was so simple.
And I think he didn't really want what I had
and I wanted a lot of what he had
without getting rid of what I had.
Like I didn't want to downgrade my house or my apartment,
but I wanted the simplicity.
So I'm trying it to live a real simple,
as simple as I can, and-
Would what would be an example
of something that maybe you cut loose?
Well, I'm not a fancy guy,
I'm not into fancy dinners.
We've talked about I only fruit until noon,
but even just wardrobe, you know?
I mean, in my closet, as soon as he left,
one of the first things I did was go through
and say, "You know what?
I only wanna have 20 things in my closet for this season."
Instead of having a couple of jackets
and a couple of this, I'm like,
"I'm gonna take the two that I like, the two sweaters,
the t-shirts, the running shorts, and that's it."
And I loved it.
It felt so clean.
And it felt even that one little small little change
opened up stuff at work.
I felt it just opened up a theme that stuck with me
about just simplifying things
and that I didn't feel like I had to return every email,
I didn't feel like emails owned me,
I took control of my own email.
So I didn't feel like I had a respond in five minutes
to every email and be beholden to that.
Or, oh, this guy's gonna get mad
if I don't respond to the email, it's like-
That's a big one.
What gives someone the right?
That someone emails me, what gives them-
Now what gives them the right to think
that I have to email them back immediately?
Why do I have to stop what I'm doing with my kids
or my family and return that email?
Shouldn't that answer be on my terms?
And pre-Goggins, I would be like,
"Oh man, so I gotta get back to him right away.
Da, da, da."
Post-Goggins, I was like, "You know what?
I'm gonna put me first."
Putting me first was a big takeaway from him.
Yeah, so you've kind of created this pie chart
about how you allocate your time every day, right?
Tell me what that looks like.
Well, I draw a circle and I start with,
okay, I need seven hours of sleep,
that's kind of where I'm comfortable operating on seven,
six isn't good for me, eight's probably a little too much.
And I said, "Okay, I have 17 hours left in a day.
How do I wanna spend it?"
And I literally put three hours for me.
And that three hours of time could be a run,
it could be sitting in a sauna, it could be doing emails,
it could be doing watching TV,
but the Jesse time is something
that I definitely prioritize.
And then I have time, a certain amount allocated time
with my wife and my family,
and the rest is pretty much work.
And that's how I break up my day.
And I approach it,
it's pretty much the same breakdown every day,
but I do change it depending on what's going on,
but I always make sure that I have three hours for me
and a certain amount of time for my wife and my kids.
And so does the training fall
into that three hours?
If you're gearing up for a race?
If I'm gearing up, I might extend it a little bit.
You know, usually training,
I usually actually keep as a separate,
the three hours usually doesn't even include the training
because again, if you're efficient with your time, 24 hours,
try to fill up on a pie chart 24 hours.
If seven of it's sleep, you still have 17 hours.
If you're efficient at work and you work X amount of hours,
you still have a lot of time.
And you know what?
Get up an hour earlier.
Right, right, right.
Yeah, that's something that I'm always trying
to find balance with that, you know?
And I feel like I vacillate between extremes.
Like in the meta, there's balance,
like if you look back over the course of a year,
my life looks really balanced, but on a day to day basis,
trying to get that mix right,
like to achieve that pie chart every single day
is something that is always alluding me.
But even if you're working a full-time job
and you work eight hours a day and you sleep six,
you have 10 hours.
You have 10 hours to allocate.
So even if I I'm trying to just figure out now
how I even do it.
Even if you ran three hours a day
and spent three hours by yourself
and three hours with your family,
you still have an hour.
Yeah.
I mean, there's a lot of time
if you don't dilly-dally.
Right.
And he didn't dilly-dally.
There was no dilly-dallying.
The dilly-dally would be like, you know what?
I got downtime, I'm gonna do some sit ups.
Everything was maximized.
Now of course it's unrealistic
for us to all live our life to that extent.
But there's pieces of it we can pull out to get better.
Do you feel like you were able
to crack his exterior
and figure out what it is that drives him?
Like what's behind that,
that has created this person?
Well, I talk about it with him
and I talk to him about it
because it's so unique and his motivator,
and we all have our own motivation, his motivator was anger.
He had a really tough childhood,
he has a lot of anger inside,
but he's been able to channel that on a daily basis
whenever he needs it.
And that's really what drives him.
He likes to look at his life as like a wet rag
that you kind of squeeze out all the water.
And he looks at the rag like it's his soul.
And he wants to squeeze out every single drip drop of water
out of his soul to know
that he's maximized his time on Earth.
But I think in some respects,
it can be said that when your fuel is anger,
that's an unsustainable fuel source, right?
You're gonna burn out.
Like at some point, is there a way to confront that fear,
work through it, get to the other side,
and be able to operate from a different place?
And did you sense, that he holds onto that?
Like if he was actually to confront that
and work through it, that suddenly he wouldn't be the person
that he is anymore or he wouldn't have that drive?
Well, I think he definitely still taps
into the anger.
He might be the exception to the rule,
he might be that one asterisk,
like on the bottom
He can go forever on that.
of the page.
You know, this doesn't apply to everyone.
Asterisks: it does apply to David Goggins.
I think he's also set up,
just he has such control of his mind.
He's convinced himself that he can just do it
or he is gonna try to do it no matter what.
And again, it goes back to being the consistency
and the discipline, he's consistently convinced himself
that he's up for the task, that he can do it,
that he was put on Earth to see what he's made of,
and so for him, maybe the anger is something
that that he can still hold onto
and maybe it is something that won't go away, I don't know.
And maybe that's channeled with other emotions
or other things or just the will to be the best
or whatever it is, but whatever that potion is
inside of him, it's working.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, the other interesting thing about the book
is it really is peppered
with a lot of business advice, you know?
It's not just, "Oh, here's how I got in shape
and here's the workouts that I did
and here's the pearls of wisdom
that David was dropping on me."
And sort of aside from him kind of
being your accessory in these business meetings,
there was some wisdom that you were able to kind of call
from hanging out with him
that has applied to your entrepreneurial life.
Yeah.
You know, I've had multiple gigs.
I had a private jet company called Marquis Jet
and I had no experience or background in private aviation,
I was in the music business,
I was a partner in ZICO Coconut Water.
So multiple, and there's always been a big learning curve.
I didn't study to be in any of those fields.
I don't think you can.
And like we said, I've never had a resume.
So I've always been like had a combination
of let me get my foot in the door
and kind of figure the rest out later.
Let me get the deal
and I'll figure out how to make the deal work.
So the first step has always been for me, getting the deal,
getting the right partners, hiring my weaknesses,
surrounding myself in filling the positions
that I didn't wanna play,
but it's always been mixed with a real passion
for stuff that I wanted to learn more about,
or get better at, or whatever.
But there's no secret sauce, you know?
It's the ability to not be scared to fail, to call audibles,
and just when you do fail,
just know that you're just getting a little nudge
that you're off course and get back on course somehow.
Yeah.
I mean, tracking back to the beginning of your career,
you have this sort of audacity to, I guess,
is it fair to say bluff your way into
the music industry
That's fair.
as Jesse James, the rapper, and then take that opportunity
once you're in the door to then translate it into,
you had a song that was on the Billboard 100, right?
Yeah.
And then realizing
there was this niche in the sports arena field
of writing these songs for these franchises
and turning that into like a full blown business.
Yes.
So do you think that...
I'm trying to figure out how to articulate this.
That your kind of audacity is just innate
or do you think that that can be taught?
I mean, that fearlessness to be able to kind of walk
into a room without a resume
and sort of secure the desired result?
Well, I always had the confidence
that if I could get into the room and connect the dots,
and put myself in the game,
that I could figure out how to get to the fourth quarter.
And when I got my record deal,
I faced rejection probably 20 times.
I sent out, like everybody trying to get a record deal
in the '80s, a cassette with a three song demo
to all the various record labels in New York and LA
and didn't hear one single word back.
And then I would call these labels and nothing.
And I didn't have a lawyer.
My dad owned a plumbing supply house,
I didn't have a powerful lawyer.
I'm like, "How in the world am I gonna get a record deal?"
Like this is crazy.
And one night I was at the studio in New York
and one of my favorite rappers of the '80s,
a guy named Dana Dane had an advanced cassette
of his second album that no one had sitting on the board,
the music board.
So I borrowed it, I put it in my pocket,
hey, I just wanted to hear it.
I was a fan of his, but when I went out to LA after college,
I had read that the owners of a record label
called Delicious Vinyl, which is a big independent,
probably the hottest independent label
in the early '90s, they had a song called Bust A Move,
Young MC, and Wild Thing from Tone Loc.
The founders loved Dana Dane.
So when I called up, I basically threw a lot of confusion,
convinced them or led them to believe that I was Dana Dane
and I set up a meeting with the owner
who was a huge fan of Dana's.
And they were referring me as Dana on the phone
and I was responding like, "Yes, you know."
"Dana, you can come at 2:00 to see Mike."
I was like, "Great, I'll be there."
And then when I rang the buzzer,
I said, "I'm Dana here to see Mike."
Dana's an African American guy from Brooklyn,
I'm a white guy from Long Island.
So obviously they didn't know what was what, but anyway,
I get all the way into this guy's office.
So the goal was to just get
in the office no matter what.
Get in the office and handcuff myself
until I get a deal or something, something.
So first you've gotta get over this hurdle
of this guy being upset
that you're not who you said you were, right?
Right, right.
So how does that go?
Well, so he comes in, by the way,
he's now a great friend of mine,
he signed my wedding license,
this guy's become a great friend,
and Dana is also a great friend, but no,
so I'm sitting in the office and the secretary comes in
and says, "Dana, can I get you some water?"
I said, "Thank you, that'd be great."
They bring water in.
And I'm waiting for Mike Ross,
the owner of this label to come in, and he comes in,
he says, "Who the hell are you?
Where's Dana?"
I said, "Oh, Dana's running a little bit late."
I said, "But I have his cassette."
You know, why don't we put it in?
I said, in fact, I have my cassette too.
He's like, "What are you talking about?"
I said, "Oh, so I've been making music with Dana for years,"
just started really confusing him even more
until finally he let me put my cassette in.
And I had a song called College Girls
and he listened to about 30 seconds of it.
I'd already-
That's a long time.
A long time.
And I'd already built a little bit of credibility,
'cause I had this cassette,
I knew a lot of the right names
and I'd been around the scene a little bit
and he stopped my song and he said,
"You know, this is great.
Would you be willing to give this song to Tone Loc,
one of his artists, and I didn't,
but it led to dialogue and going down the path
and ultimately, my record deal.
Right, that's amazing.
And is it that same sort of spirit
that you took to Marquis Jet?
Everything.
You know, how did that happen?
Everything in my life has been like that.
Marquis Jet, similar thing.
You know, I was a guest on a private jet,
loved the experience,
my partner and I were literally sitting
in the back of a friend of ours who invited us on a trip
on one of his planes.
And we were like, this is unbelievable.
How do we fly like this more often?
And came up with this idea for a 25 hour flight card,
which ultimately became Marquis Jet,
and had this great, we really thought
that there would be a huge market for people
that would wanna buy this 25 hour prepaid card.
The problem was we had no airplanes.
So we had to go to NetJets who was the 800 pound gorilla.
And I gotten a call about a year prior to that
from a friend of mine
who wanted to put one of his friend's daughters,
wanted to get tickets to a Christina Aguilera concert
and knew that I knew the manager
from my days in the music business.
And I didn't know who the guy was,
but not only did we get this gal, the 16 year old,
for her birthday tickets, she had the opportunity
to be a background singer on this studio,
the guy was gonna do me a favor, the manager.
And it turns out that the fellow
whose daughter it was, this guy, Jim Jacobs,
who was the president of NetJets.
So when we had this idea a year later, I called.
Now, he doesn't know me.
I was like the the behind the scenes guy
that facilitated this thing.
I get him on the phone.
Again, just, he had no idea what I was talking about.
I'm like, "Christina Aguilera."
He is like, "You're Aguilera?"
I'm like, "No."
You know, da, da, I'm like, "No, your daughter..."
Just started.
Harry Truman has this great line,
"If you can't convince 'em, confuse 'em."
So that's kind of been my-
Starting to get that this is your tactic.
Yeah, just get everyone super confused.
Yeah.
It led to a meeting.
And we took a meeting and presented our plan for Marquis Jet
and we were faced with the no.
You know, like, "This is not for us.
We're not gonna give two 30 year old kids,"
I was 30 at the time, "our fleet of airplanes
to try some kind of jet card program."
And we ended up going back a week later.
And instead of just taking that no,
we brought in our own focus group of athletes
and entertainers and agents that talked about,
one-by-one, got up, we literally set up chairs
like it was a focus group
and discussed why they would never buy a share
of an airplane or their own airplane,
but they would buy what we were proposing,
this 25 hour card.
And it ended up being a really big business.
That's interesting.
I mean, with that knowledge,
why wouldn't NetJets just create that internally?
I think two reasons,
Take that idea.
I think one: I don't think they really thought
it would be as big as it became.
And two: we were in that demo.
We could reach that young customer and the athlete
and talk to that guy better than they could.
They were set up really to sell corporate
and to high net worth older individuals.
We were selling to a much younger,
we were selling to the Kobe Bryants of the world.
And I think that they thought,
"Well, if there's gonna be any success,
let's see if these guys can sell to that world."
And we did.
Yeah, the one thing that you really seem to get
is the value and importance
of having that kind of celebrity endorser.
And that seems to be like a cornerstone
of every business that you get into is making sure
that it's sort of cool with those people, right?
When they're signing on for it,
that creates this ripple effect that then drives demand.
Yes and no, though.
The no to that is the product has to be great
because celebrity will get someone to buy the product once
and it'll get you on the shelves,
but it won't get 'em to buy it twice.
So you have to win 'em with great product.
Marquis Jet was a great product
and ZICO Coconut Water was a great product.
I love that story of how you chased
after Matt Damon and Ben Affleck
when you found out they were gonna be flying
on some other client of yours share
on their way to Sundance, right?
Yeah, we had just started Marquis Jet
and every day, I got a manifest of who was on the planes,
who was flying with us.
And Matt was a guest and Ben were guests of somebody else,
I saw their name, and I was in New York.
And I was like,
we were trying to build out the Hollywood vertical.
So I was like,
"I have to get them to sign up to our program.
So I literally was in the cab
and at the time I was running a lot, I was wearing shorts,
it was winter, I was in shorts,
I'm not even kidding, going to work.
And I said to the guy, "Take me to LaGuardia.
And I just got on a plane to LA
'cause their plane was flying
from LA to the Sundance Film Festival.
So I flew to LA, I met him on the plane,
I introduced myself as Jesse,
one of the co-founders of Marquis Jet and coincidence,
I'm going to Sundance also.
You know, do you mind if I guys...
They had a huge upgrade scheduling,
just on a fluke, they had a big plane.
So I could actually sit and kind of like with a staff
where to sit or on like a jump seat.
So I told 'em, "I was just gonna quietly jump up
if you needed me, da, da, da."
And then once we got in the air,
I started talking to them.
And Nate said to me that they were having,
"A nice to meet you."
We said, "Look, we're going
to this project green light release.
If you wanna come, you can come meet us.
Love to see you at the event at Sundance."
Now, first of all, I had no clothing,
I had no hotel, it's Sundance, everything is sold out,
it's freezing, I'm in shorts.
You have no hotel there
or anyplace to stay.
I have nothing.
Nothing.
And I'm like, "Oh, I got meetings.
You know, this whole thing."
And I get off the plane.
So I get some stuff,
I check into the hotel like 20 miles away.
I'm like, you know what?
I didn't close the deal, I gotta go to this thing.
So I show up to the project green light event,
there's 2000 people online.
I'm like, how am I gonna get into here?
So I went right up to the front of the line
and I said, "Hey guys, I'm here with Matt and Ben,
I'm on their advanced team
to make sure that the tables are set up."
The guy opened up the velvet rope, walked right in,
and then I went upstairs to the VIP table
and I took a black marker and I wrote my last name,
Itzler, on a piece of paper.
And I wrote reserved on another piece of paper.
And I put it on the tabletops next to Matt's table
where it said like the VIP thing.
And I literally walked in there and sat next to those guys.
And I asked them when they were flying home.
They said, "You know, we don't have anything booked yet."
I said, "Why don't you guys fly home with me?
Which I wasn't flying home.
And on the flight home, I sold them a card.
Right, there you go.
That's a great story, man.
Yeah, we laugh about it still.
The balls of that is incredible,
but did you tell them how the whole thing?
Oh yeah.
They know the story.
Oh yeah, now when I talk to those guys about it,
they crack up.
Yeah, that's fantastic.
I love that.
So-
When we got back on the plane,
Matt's manager said to me,
he said to turn to Matt on the plane ride home and he goes,
"What's the manager from the club doing on our plane?"
No one knew what was going on.
That's great, man.
So ultimately, you exit Marquis,
it sells to Berkshire Hathaway, right?
Yeah.
And at some point running enters the picture,
like when does that start to creep in?
So I decided, you know,
I ran this relay race years ago
in San Diego, a 24 hour relay.
And it was wild because I got
to see people run 100 miles by themselves,
which I never thought was even possible.
And I just was always planted a seed in my head
that it was something that I would love to see
if I was capable of doing.
And I decided I wanted to raise money
for a bunch of foundations
and I just signed up for this 24 hour race with 100.
I was gonna stop at 100 if I got there.
So I took 90 days off from work.
I wouldn't say off, but committed 90 days during work
to train for this race.
And I trained like, I mean, I was going berserk,
morning, night.
You know, I would work and then I would just to prepare
for the sleep deprivation.
I would work till 11 and then run till six in the morning
and then go back to work.
You know, all this stuff.
And so that was really where I got the bug.
And then running takes a lot, I'm a big 6'2" guy,
and I'm not really built like a runner,
but I got the endurance bug
and started doing some standup paddle races
and anything that just looked exciting.
Right.
And so how did that 100 miler go for you?
You know, I had a really good game plan going in.
I spent these 90 days talking to anyone
that'd ever run 100 miles, reading everything, hydration,
nutrition, had a great game plan.
And I stuck to it until I couldn't stick to it
because, as you know-
In 100 miles, it's gonna break loose on you.
It broke loose around 60.
And 75, it flew away.
But I gutted it out, but it put me in a wheelchair.
I was banged up.
Oh, wow.
My hips and joints were really banged up
and my feet were battered.
I mean, totally battered.
But this is the best thing I ever did in my life.
And you raised a bunch of money, right?
Like a million and a half bucks.
And this is for the foundation that you started, right?
Yep.
And I distributed it to 10 different US based charity,
charitable organizations.
And does the foundation still exist?
It does.
Like what's going on with that?
You know,
I'm new to this whole philanthropy stuff.
You know, I'm still trying to figure out
what the best way to deploy resources is.
So I'm going to a lot of conferences and listening
and talking to a lot of people,
but the foundation still exists.
100 Mile Foundation.
100 Mile Man Foundation, yeah.
And since then, I've done multiple 100 mile challenges
to raise money for the foundation.
And I also put my own money into the foundation,
but we did a 100 mile bike ride
called City to the Sand from New York City to the Hamptons.
And we had 100 CEOs that each raised 10 grand,
so a million dollars.
We've done a 100 mile spin thing in Central Park.
I've done a thing called Hell on the Hill.
In my backyard, I have a really big incline
in my house in Connecticut, it's about a 35% grade
that's about a little less than 100 yards.
And we go up and down 100 times,
about eight and a half miles.
But it's hard.
Really hard.
That's hard.
It's really brutally hard.
It only takes about, you know,
well actually Goggins won it this year.
He wanted a 1:55, but it takes a regular human anywhere
from three to four hours, but it is brutal.
Right.
And so what does running mean to you,
like in your life equation?
Like how does that impact your family life,
your entrepreneurial life?
Well, it's my form of meditation.
So if I don't run, I feel way worse.
It's not a good day if I don't run.
I'm just not connected to myself.
You know, I'm a little grumpy.
But it's become habit for me.
It's worked into my pie chart.
It's one of the things that I have to do.
And it doesn't have to be a run, it could be a paddle,
it could be burpees, it could be something,
but the running, you know, I don't listen to music,
it's a very spiritual thing for me.
And it's just my way of clearing my head
and starting my day.
Never any music.
Never.
And in the 100 miler?
I had a playlist that I knew I would probably need
to get me through some part of it.
And I put it on at mile 93,
So the last couple of miles, I took it off.
But no, I don't like to listen to music.
I like to be totally clear on my thoughts.
I do my best thinking when I'm running.
Lately, I've been run walking.
I've been walking too, which I love, and that's my time.
Where's the best place to run around here?
Well, now I'm in Atlanta.
I live in Atlanta full time.
And in my neighborhood, there's a ton of runners.
It's hilly, there's rolling hills,
there's a nice four mile loop.
So I do that a couple times.
There's some good hills.
And I love running steps.
So I'll go to the stadium and I'll just run steps
for an hour or something and I love that.
Well, that's a good time to good place
to segue into the Atlanta Hawks.
So this is new for you, right?
Yep.
Part owner of the Hawks.
Tell me what that's like.
Like, what does that mean in terms of your involvement
and your participation in the organization?
Well, I'm a huge basketball fan.
So I mean, there couldn't be anything more fun
and I love our organization and our team.
I've been a season ticket holder here in Atlanta
for a couple of years.
So I've been around the organization
and it's just such a pleasure and honor to work
with the players and the staff we have and the community.
It's great.
And we're new to this, we bought the team,
a small group of bunch of guys that I knew, friends,
and a couple guys here in Atlanta.
And we've only been on board for about three or four months,
so we're still learning.
There's a lot of work to do,
but I can't even explain it, it's just been phenomenal.
It's so crazy that like the guy
who's writing these theme songs for the teams.
I mean, if anyone would've said like this guy one day
is gonna be an owner of one of the franchises,
I mean, you can't script that, man.
No.
It's unbelievable, yeah
It's impossible.
It's so crazy.
And lucky and fortunate and believe me,
I appreciate every minute of it
and it's been great, it's been great.
So what is it your involvement entail?
Like what does it look like in terms of your input
or lack of input or your relationship with the players
and all of that?
Well, because I'm here in Atlanta,
a big part of it is community related.
We've built five basketball courts in the inner cities
here in Atlanta recently and we have 25 more in the works.
And so a combination of community efforts,
a combination of some of the marking stuff,
I've done a lot of work in the past with the NBA.
So that's an area that I wanna focus on
and that I think we can get better in.
But all the basketball stuff,
we leave for the coaches and the coaching staff
and guys that have a lot more experience
and expertise than myself and my partners.
Well, these guys must know you have this book,
obviously, out, right?
Oh yeah.
So is your kind of like lifestyle habits wearing
off on any of the players?
You know, I'm lucky because one of the guys,
Kyle Korver, one of our players,
does a thing called the Musagi every year,
which is Japanese term, I don't know the exact specifics,
but basically you do something
that you do not think you could possibly finish
that can completely test your will
and challenge your soul, for example.
And this is a guy on our team.
Right.
So he loves-
It's like right up your alley, yeah.
Last year, he and a friend,
took, I believe it was like 60 or an 80 pound boulder
and dropped it in five feet of ocean water
and they would dive down one by one and move the boulder
for three miles.
It took him like 17 hours.
Oh wow.
And of course, there's all kinds of challenges,
physical fatigue, mental.
And every year, this guy.
So when I heard this story, I'm like, this is perfect.
Perfect for me.
So I gave Kyle the book and he loved it,
told me he started doing some of these push up
and pull-up challenges and this and that.
So the guys, look, I think they can relate
to the whole 100 mile experience
and what the preparation that it took and the will.
And they're professional athletes,
they go through their same challenges.
Like how do you get up for a game 80 times a year?
I mean, it's a lot, what these guys go through.
You don't realize it.
You say, "Oh, these guys are getting paid
to play basketball," but no, it's grueling.
It's physical, it's exhausting, there's travel,
there's other life stuff going on, family,
and they have to get up and perform every night.
And we have a team of guys that do that.
I mean, they're diving for loose balls
and jumping in the bleachers.
So it's great to see.
Have you ever thought about bringing David out
to talk with the guys?
Absolutely.
They all know the story and it's in the works
and he be a great motivator for these guys.
I love that, man, that's fantastic.
Very cool.
All right, well, you're married
to an amazingly successful entrepreneur.
Between the two of you, you have very rich business lives,
you also have three kids.
How do you like find that work life balance
in terms of making sure that you're attending
to your relationship?
You know, she's busy, you're busy,
you're doing all these things.
You've got this great family and young kids.
So how does that work?
Well, I'm not gonna lie, it's hard, you know?
I would be lying to say that it's not challenging.
Sarah's got her business and a lot of responsibilities
and her foundation,
which is a lot bigger than my foundation.
And trying to manage all of this stuff
with our kids is hard,
but we're very mindful of our time,
we make sure that we have a date night
or date nights every week,
we eat as a family all the time,
we share ideas all the time,
we carve out time for walks and try to make it work.
Are you on each other's sort of board of advisors
in terms of like bouncing ideas off each other
in a business way, or do you guys have rules
around when you talk about business and when you don't?
You know what?
We bounce new ideas off of each other a lot.
I don't get it too into Sarah's business
and she doesn't get too into mine, however,
what better person or advisor than my wife?
I mean, she's just an incredible business mind,
incredibly creative.
So I had the luxury of turning to my left in the morning
and saying, "Sweetie, what do you think of this idea?"
And getting the advice of a consultant,
of a high paid consultant.
If she's like, "No, it's a terrible idea."
And then you go and do it anyway.
That doesn't happen.
Doesn't happen?
She trumps everything.
In fact, if something is fully baked
and she's like, you know what?
This should be blue, not red.
It's blue.
Yep.
That's a smart man.
That's the marriage secret right there, right?
Yep.
I learned two things in this marriage.
One is I'm never gonna question my wife's decisions
when it comes to business or business decisions,
and two is I'm not gonna compete with her
or anything 'cause she's too good.
Right, and sitting,
like for those that are listening,
right to my left are two pictures hanging on the wall.
One of her on the cover of Forbes
and the other one on the cover of Time magazine.
So I think she stands from a place of authority on this.
Yeah, she's unbelievable.
Cool.
Well, let's talk about the diet a little bit
and then we can wrap it up.
But you got a really interesting take on nutrition.
Yeah.
Only fruit before noon
is that's what sort of grabs the headline,
but there's a lot more going on there too, isn't there?
Yeah, I mean, I read a book called Fit for Life
and I was fortunate enough to get this book early in my life
when I was running my first marathon
and the book was written by a guy named Harvey Diamond
and his wife, Marilyn Diamond.
And I don't know what attracted me to the book,
but I couldn't put it down.
And one of the principles was to only fruit until noon
because digestion takes more energy than anything.
And we want energy, we don't want to use energy.
So the more efficiently we can digest food,
and obviously the more processed foods, the more meats,
the more animal products, et cetera,
the harder it is to digest, the less energy.
The bigger the breakfast, the less energy.
So that was one of the big takeaways for me.
And I tried it for 10 days.
I said, "You know what?
I've been eating bagels every morning.
I've been eating cereals,"
and I just switched over to fresh cut fruit.
When was that?
How long ago was that?
'92.
And I was getting ready to run my first marathon.
And after about 10 days, I said, "You know what?
Let me go back and have my old breakfast.
Let me make some bagels and eggs and this kind of thing."
And I felt terrible.
And I was like, "Holy cow, this is unbelievable."
And I lost weight, I got lean, I was running like a machine.
I was recovering better.
Everything got better.
And then there were other takeaways in the book,
not to mix proteins and starches,
other takeaways, and it's been something
that I've been unwavering on.
I'm a vegetarian, I'm a vegan.
I eat pretty much 80%, I'm a vegan 90% of the time,
I'm raw 80% of the time.
And it's just been people ask me the same questions
they probably ask you, where do you get your protein?
All these things.
Well, also right now
with this kind of low carb craze,
like the idea that you shouldn't be eating fruit,
that's like bad for you.
You know, I'm sure you get a lot of questions like that.
I eat 15 bananas a day.
I've never missed a day of work.
I run all the time, I have crazy energy,
At least in my opinion,
I've never met anyone that's protein deficient,
I just got all my blood work done,
I think I came back like I'm 18 years old, I'm 47.
Not to jinx anything, anything can happen,
but on a daily basis, I feel good.
And I would say to everybody,
there's all kinds of theories, right?
Have milk, don't have milk, have fruit, don't have fruit,
too much sugar and fruit, too much this.
Try different things and see how your body reacts
and how you feel.
For me, this worked great.
And I haven't changed off of the deviated
from the path in 25 plus years.
And how does it work with your wife and your kids?
Oh, my wife eats French fries
and cheeseburgers and eats like a linebacker.
It's not rubbing off on her?
But that's what works for her.
And no, for my kids, I have a couple of rules.
One is the first thing in the morning for my six year old,
he has to eat something that's alive.
So I don't wanna him eating something processed.
And then if he wants to have a waffle, he can have a waffle,
but I really encourage him to have a piece of fruit
or fresh squeezed orange juice
or a banana before the waffle.
And I just encourage him to make healthy decisions.
I mean, he's around me, so he knows my commitment to it
and how important it is to me
and I try to teach him as much as I can, but he's six.
And in this country, it's hard.
And I'll tell you the hardest thing for me as a parent,
because of my passion for food,
is when my son goes to school and other parents
are deciding what my son is gonna eat that day.
Right, right.
And especially at this age,
when the habits are just forming, right?
And you wanna be able to exercise some influence
and control over that with an eye towards the long term,
but then knowing that like most of their day
or half of their days at school
where you're not involved in that.
Right.
And you guys open that-
Gonna have a neg.
Right.
So we're gonna have a celebration for Thanksgiving
or Halloween or whatever.
You know, why do we have to have everything?
Like, I mean, it's just crazy to me.
So anyway, that's challenging
and frustrating.
Yeah,
you do the best you can.
Do the best you can.
All right, I wanna wrap it up
with one final inquiry around relationships,
'cause I gather like from you
and just sort of poking around the internet,
I'm getting a sense of who you are and how you function,
that relationships are really at the center
of your kind of success equation.
Like not in a sort of conscious way of building a network,
but just an appreciation for the value of relationships,
like in your life and business and outside of business.
Yeah, it is very important.
It's the single most important thing for me in business.
I didn't over index in any category as it relates to not,
you know, as you would think it would relate to business,
but I've been able to get, I think,
to advance and move the ball down field
based on just authentic relationships
and really just one of the best things
about being successful, having a little bit of money
or whatever, is being able to spoil your friends and family
and those that you care about and to help people.
And I think I had that in me before anything
when I was living with my parents in my house.
I think I've always had that.
And I think that it's translated
into real good relationships and in your '20s and '30s,
you never know who's gonna be in a position of power
in you '40s and '50s,
but the guys that I've come up with in my '20s,
there's always a couple of guys or gals
that are in really big decision making positions.
And if you have those relationships,
you maintain 'em, and they're authentic,
they'll be very rewarding.
I feel like you understood that your '20s
are a good time to really explore yourself
and figure out what you really want to do
before committing to anything
as opposed to just getting on a train
and trying to sort of move up a corporate ladder.
But I had to rely on meeting people.
I had to rely on, you know,
I didn't have an ivey education or anything like that.
I had to rely on those relationships.
My '20s were spent meeting people
and cultivating relationships, staying in touch,
inviting people, including people that I liked,
getting rid of people that I didn't like,
and maintaining those friendships.
And that was a huge part of my '20s.
I mean, spending my nights,
I tried to own the nights more than the days.
What do you mean by that?
You know, those were key hours for me in the '20s.
That's when people were going out, making friendships,
it wasn't about work,
it was just about who you got along with
and I would go out all the time.
I wasn't a drinker, I wasn't a partier, but I would go out.
I was out, I was active, I was getting phone numbers,
returning calls, meeting people,
inviting them, connecting dots.
And then I would lean on people when I need it.
You know, people generally like to help people.
I'm seeing it with my book now.
You know, so many of my friends have been so supportive,
even people from 20 years ago.
So you just don't know.
Yeah, you're getting crazy tweets.
You know, you got Maria Shriver tweet it.
Did Trump tweet your book?
Trump, LeBron.
Trump?
Yeah.
That's insane, man.
Yeah, yeah.
But, and also I think, look,
the book is a fun read, it's a fun, funny read.
You can read it in like two hours,
three hours, in one sitting.
it's really easy and fun to read.
But people are doing it on their own.
And I think it's out of a true appreciation
for a genuine friendship, you know?
I think most people are, you know,
we're habits of routine and routine has its place
and I like routines and I'm productive in routines,
but really the call to action of this book
is to shake up your routine,
to get out of your routine,
and to really take a look in the mirror
and challenge yourself to do something
that makes you uncomfortable in a culture
that values sort of security and comfort above all.
You know, so there's all of that to overcome.
And I love that about it.
And one of the things that really stuck with me
that I think I'm gonna spend a lot of time thinking about
is that Goggins accountability mirror.
Yes.
So tell me what that is.
Well, I mean, he's been shaving his head
and his face every morning since he's 18 years old,
because he wanted to be comfortable
with the reflection in the mirror.
He wanted to see his whole face and look into his soul
and be comfortable with what he saw.
And if he wasn't, he was gonna make changes.
And I think Goggin's whole thing
is he's sick of people feeling sorry for themselves.
It's like, we have to be accountable for ourself,
there's an accountability mirror,
that's what he looks in every day,
and you gotta be comfortable
with your reflection in the mirror.
And I agree with him.
You know, we live in a world of a lot of excuses and blame,
but where's the accountability, you know?
Like if you didn't run today, whose fault is that?
You don't blame it on your schedule, go and do it.
So if someone's listening to this
and they are one of those people
that fall into that category of being in a rut
or perhaps stuck in a job they don't like
or circumstances that they feel
like they don't have control over,
what is your call to action as the first step to shift that?
It's just, you have to be willing
to get uncomfortable to get better
and you have to just take that first step
to reap the rewards.
And really, there's no silver bullet.
There's nothing.
There's nothing, it's you.
And you have to just do it yourself.
No one could tell you to do it,
you can't read a book or this,
you have to wanna do it for you.
And when you wanna do it, you'll do it.
You did it.
Look at you, you turned your whole life around
from the bottom.
But pain is the motivator.
You know what I mean?
Like I was in a sufficient enough pain
that I was ready to make that shift.
You know, how do you make that shift
without the elevator going all the way down?
And you were sick of you.
You wanted a different you.
Yeah, that's true.
So you gotta want it.
You gotta want it,
but you gotta real authentically want it,
not just say you want it.
Thanks for talking to me, man.
Appreciate it.
Yeah, really appreciate it.
The book is Living with a Seal.
If you're digging on Jesse,
the best way to connect with you
is you're @The100MileMan on Twitter and the website is?
The 100mileman.
The number 100.
The number 100mileman.com.
Yeah, and you're on Facebook and all
those other places, right?
Yeah.
You're an easy guy to track down online.
All right, cool, man.
Congrats on the book, man.
It's really a great read.
Everybody should pick it up and check it out,
and it will improve your life, I think,
and at least make you think about stuff,
I think, a little bit more deeply, so.
Thank you.
Thanks man.
Peace.
Bye.
(jazzy music)